[Musique]
un bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi 5 juillet la
question des primaires à moins d'un an
de l'échéance des présidentielles de
2022 valérie pécresse laurent wauquiez
avait mort à un bruno retailleau
demandent ensemble ce soir une primaire
ouverte de la droite et du centre dans
une tribune publiée dans le figaro le
jour même où guillaume pelletier numéro
deux du parti officialisé sont soutien à
xavier bertrand chez les verts delphine
batho elle vient d'officialiser sa
candidature pour la primaire de
septembre prochain qui l'opposera entre
autres à eric bien les l'eurodéputé
yannick jadot onf états unis
une question se pose quant à l'ouverture
des frontières si certains pensaient que
celle ci serait tranchée où tout le
monde ou du moins évoquée durant le
discours de joe biden hier lors de la
fête nationale
ils ont vu leurs espoirs déçus pour
l'heure les règles d'accès au territoire
américain sont inchangées un éventuel
allègement reste à guetter promesses du
bric site le royaume uni durci le ton
sur la politique d'immigration annonce
en mars dernier le projet de loi sera
discutée demain au parlement
le pays vient en effet d'enregistrer le
record du nombre de traversées de la
manche avec plus de 6000 depuis le 1er
janvier les clandestins pourront écoper
jusqu'à quatre ans de prison contre six
mois initialement les passeurs risque la
prison à vie
[Musique]
en france les régionales terminées place
désormais à la présidentielle les partis
politiques sont sur le qui vive pour
désigner leur candidat la question des
primaires est sur toutes les lèvres mais
d'autres notamment à droite sont
traumatisés par ce processus de
désignation et préfère une confrontation
directe avec les électeurs et minard
bensaïd a au lendemain des élections
régionales et à la proche de la
présidentielle de 2000 22
l'idée des primaires au sein des parties
prend de l'ampleur elle serait pour
certains
l'outil idéal pour trouver le bon
candidat ce lundi après-midi dans une
tribune des figures du parti des
républicains ont appelé à une primaire
ouverte de la droite et du centre
parmi les signataires valérie pécresse
actuelle présidente de la région ile de
france laurent wauquiez à la tête de la
région auvergne rhône-alpes
le sénateur bruno retailleau ou encore
hervé morin président de la région
normandie il faut donc s'en remettre au
système le plus clair le plus
démocratique
le vote un vote populaire le plus large
possible
ouvert à tous les sympathisants de la
droite et du centre à droite la primaire
ne fait pourtant pas l'unanimité
le candidat à la présidentiel xavier
bertrand
reconduit président de la région des
hauts de france est catégorique j'ai une
conception gaullienne de l'élection
présidentielle c'est la rencontre d'un
homme ou d'une femme
avec les français autour d'une vision et
d'un projet c'est pourquoi je ne
souhaite plus m'inscrire dans la logique
d'un seul parti
je ne participerai pas à une primaire si
la primaire a mauvaise presse auprès de
certains candidats potentiels c'est
notamment parce qu'elle est à l'origine
de l'échec des républicains qui avaient
élu françois fillon pour 2017 et dont la
crédibilité avait été mise à mal par
plusieurs affaires judiciaires
même constat au parti socialiste dont le
candidat benoît hamon avait réalisé un
score particulièrement bas avec 6,8 pour
cent des votes au premier tour de la
présidentielle de 2017
le parti emmené par olivier faur attend
leur congrès des 18 et 19 septembre pour
désigner son candidat
plusieurs mouvances cohabitent au sein
de la formation avec d'un côté les
partisans de la maire de paris anne
hidalgo
ceux de françois hollande ou encore les
soutiens de carole delga qui incarne la
nouvelle génération du parti plus à
gauche
l'option des primaires n'est pas encore
avancé officiellement trois candidats
sont en lice le communiste fabien
roussel le leader de la france insoumise
jean luc mélenchon et celle ou celui
qu'europe écologie les verts décidera
d'investir le 12 septembre
du côté des écologistes la question de
la primaire ait tranché et c'est le oui
qui l'emportent avec un premier tour
prévue entre le 16 et le 19 septembre
elle départagera delphine batho qui a
annoncé sa candidature lundi matin
sandrine rousseau
eric piolle yannick jadot ancien
candidat à la présidentielle et jean
marc governatori d'autres candidats
peuvent encore se présenter jusqu'au 12
juillet une primaire que le parti a
choisi d'ouvrir à tous les électeurs
sans conditions d'adhésion une nouvelle
forme de scrutin que les écologistes
espèrent efficace dans un parti où les
désaccords idéologiques ont souvent été
légion et la primaire ce sera l'objet du
bureau politique des républicains en
demain séance qui s'annonce agitée entre
ceux qui veulent une primaire ouverte et
ceux qui veulent une primaire fermée
ceux qui n'en veulent carrément pas
alors faut-il recommencer une grande
primaire comme en 2016 la même question
se pose aussi à gauche en ce moment est
ce une opération risquée pour les partis
politiques c'est l'objet de notre
décryptage
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec alain
houpert sénateur a l'air de côte-d'or on
serait de remettre un présent au bureau
politique alain perrin des républicains
bonsoir à vous et à vos côtés yves
d'amécourt des mes cours par d'anciens
élèves
vous êtes aujourd'hui le porte parole
national du mouvement de la ruralité
merci d'être avec nous avec nos
également alexis poulain notre
éditorialiste bonsoir alexis alors pour
la première fois dans une tribune ce
soir au figaro valérie pécresse laurent
wauquiez et hervé morin bruno retailleau
demandent ensemble à une primaire
ouverte de la droite et du centre dans
une tribune donc publié ce soir votre
réaction alain houpert c'est une bonne
chose pour vous ce mérite débat et on a
sur les primaires une très mauvaise
expérience
souvenez-vous de 2017 et et les
primaires c'est c'est quelque chose
d'anglo saxons c'est pas dans notre adn
et surtout républicains c'est une
politique spectacle
la terre et télé réalité et celui qui
sort vainqueur des primaires sort
affaiblie je dirais cramer parce qu'il a
sorti tous ces arguments pour la
présidentielle et il va lors de la
présidentielle se continuer à débattre
avec les mêmes phrases avec les mêmes
arguments au risque de lasser des
électeurs et nous sommes dans une
période difficile
je pense que ce serait indécent de faire
de la politique
réalité de faire de faire la roue de
faire le paon pendant cette pandémie
pendant sept 7 france vivent cette
france vit dans une période difficile
chaque huitième on nous annonce le en
général olivier devron nous annoncent
eux une semaine catastrophique
nous venons d'assister à des des projets
de lois liberticides le la france est
dans une
période dramatique je pense qu'il faut
comme le disait monsieur bertrand être
dans une stature gaullienne et je pense
qu'on peut décider entre nous de savoir
qui va être le candidat à la
présidentielle parce que la
présidentielle ces deux tours et il faut
être
il est patrie angulaire il faut être au
deuxième tour il ya trois parties qui
sont capables de mettre un candidat au
deuxième tour il ya le col parti
présidentiel emmanuel macron il ya le
front national le rassemblement national
il y à la droite et le centre et je
n'imagine pas emmanuel macron son parti
et le rassemblement national faire une
primaire donc nous seront
automatiquement affaibli face à ces deux
candidats il faut que le candidat de la
droite et du centre et les dernières
élections le montrer la france est à
droite
il faut que ce que notre candidat soit
désigné soit au deuxième tour alors
allez on perd on aimerait bien pour vous
que ça soit aussi simple enfin
s'assemble
en tout cas mal engagé tout sur le point
de la santé cité à cette heure puisque
xavier bertrand lui on rappelle qu'il a
claqué la porte du parti en 2017 mais il
n'empêche c'est un candidat de droite
il n'en veut pas de cette primaire il a
dit d'ores et déjà qu'il n'irait pas
xavier bertand d'ailleurs qui enregistre
aujourd'hui même alors que cette tribune
est publiée
un soutien celui de numéro deux des
républicains guillaume pelletier vice
président délégué on écoute je considère
que nous avons désormais un candidat
naturel
xavier bertrand est le mieux placé
d'entre nous le seul capable de battre
emmanuel macron est de faire gagner la
droite il daniel coureau c'est quoi ce
soir cette tribune c'est une manière de
mettre la pression sur xavier bertrand
oh bah c'est tout simplement des gens
qui s'inquiètent
on est à huit mois l'élection
présidentielle et les républicains qui
est le parti leader de la droite et du
centre n'a toujours pas choisi de
méthodes de départage alors que ses
statuts prévoient une primaire ouverte
donc en fait les républicains depuis
2010 est avait deux missions
la première c'était de construire un
projet d'alternance et la deuxième
c'était d'organiser une méthode de
départage ces deux missions elles n'ont
pas été menées à bien et on a même
choisi au moment où on a renouvelé le
président des républicains
un président en lui demandant de
s'engager à ne pas être candidat à quoi
que ce soit alors que dans l'esprit du
parti c'était le président du parti qui
était le candidat naturel et donc on a
un président de parti qui est le nom
candidat naturel et donc rien n'a été
fait pour choisir un candidat
et aujourd'hui on nous propose un
sondage auprès de quinze mille personnes
pour choisir le candidat de la droite et
du centre
autant vous dire que ça ressemble pas à
grand chose puisque quand on regarde les
sondages qui ont eu lieu avant les
élections régionales
les résultats ont été tout autre que
ceux annoncés par les sondages et quand
on se souvient un des rêves et des
sondages avant la primaire de 2016
jusqu'à la veille le sondage qui a eu
lieu la veille de la primaire
donner les trois candidats ex-aequo
alors qu'en fait il ya eu des
différences énormes entre les entre les
trois candidats de la primaire
donc tout ça ne ressemble à rien donc
jean leonetti a été investie d'une
mission qui est de proposer une solution
de départage je crois qu'aujourd'hui il
ya deux solutions de départage qui sont
sur la table soit une primaire ouverte
je crois que la primaire fermée c'est
fermé puisque toute façon les dirigeants
même des républicains choisissent des
candidats à l'extérieur des républiques
donc de toute façon dans une logique
ouverte et l'autre solution qui avait
été abordé par jean leonetti c'était de
consulter cent cinquante mille élus
locaux voilà donc je pense que mardi il
y aura un choix entre ces deux solutions
mais par contre il faut aller vite
puisque pour pouvoir présenter un
candidat l'année prochaine il faut qu'il
ya un débat l'intérêt d'un choix entre
plusieurs candidats c'est de pouvoir les
entendre sur leurs projets et donc il
faut pouvoir les entendre sur leurs
projets et comme christian jacob dit le
30 septembre on se mettra d'accord sur
une méthode pour choisir début novembre
c'est pas sérieux on est en train de
parler de l'avenir de la france
on a assez reproché au président
emmanuel macron d'être dans
l'improvisation permanente et son
prédécesseur avant lui c'est pas pour
choisir un candidat qui n'aura pas de
projet et sans avoir travaillé sur le
fond comme l'avaient fait les candidats
à la primaire de 2016
on avait eu le droit en 2016 un vrai
débat sur le fond qui avait passionné
les français et qui avait fait que 4
millions de français s'étaient rendus
aux urnes pour choisir le candidat de la
droite et du centre
l'autre vertus que je vois moi à une
élection primaire c'est que dans une
élection primaire ne votent que les gens
qui seront que se reconnaissent dans les
valeurs de la droite et du centre
et donc le débat a bien lieu sur un
programme de droite alors que quand on
envoie quelqu'un de sans connaître son
projet finalement il va nous proposer un
programme centriste et on va de nouveau
repartir dans un dans un nom mandat sans
régler les problèmes
sans proposer les vraies solutions sans
proposer finalement ce qu'attendent
notre ce qu'attend notre électorat
alexis poulain cette droite à ce qu'elle
a intérêt à ces primaires où la machine
à perdre
ça y est les lancers auto temps publié
directement l'acte de décès faire la
nécrologie des parties particulièrement
des républicains s'il décide en corse de
partir sur une primaire ouverte
clairement ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que ce sont des partis qui sont
incapables de se renouveler d'aller
chercher des militants d'aller aussi
animer un débat démocratique interne qui
va faire qu'il ya d'émotion qu'il ya des
projets qu'il ya des hommes et des
femmes aussi qu'ils sortent qui se
démarque parce qu'ils sont porteurs de
projet et parce qu'ils ont su fédérer en
interne
allez dire que les sondages et des
primaires ouvertes c'est à dire quoi une
à l'échalote va faire que on va
sélectionner un candidat parce qu'il
sera finalement le plus tendance à le
plus hype eu à un moment donné c'est
ridicule on arrête la politique en
réalité on accepte que la politique est
devenue un spectacle et qu'il n'y a plus
de débat d'idées qu'il n'ya plus
réellement quelqu'un qui porte un projet
pour ce pays qui va mal un monsieur ou
pearl à la betty et je partage tout à
fait son analyse il n'est plus temps de
tergiverser et de faire semblant
aujourd'hui je crois que les nombreux
électeurs les nombreux électeurs qui se
déplacent parce que rial abstention qui
fait que les gens ne veulent plus et
pourquoi parce que justement la
politique n'intéresse plus parce que la
politique ne fait plus de politique
elle fait du spectacle au mieux et sinon
elle fait du marketing et de la vente à
la découpe du pays c'est ce que fait
emmanuel macron depuis maintenant quatre
ans
donc aujourd'hui si que les républicains
veulent un candidat eh bien ça se
discute en interne ça se discute aussi
avec de nombreux militants ça fait que
la démocratie est vivante parce que les
partis sont vivants donc ce qui
m'inquiète moi aujourd'hui c'est de voir
qu'on est seulement à huit mois d'une
élection majeure et qu'aucun parti n'a
organisé et les républicains pas plus
qu'un autre
cette démocratie interne cette recherche
des militants de labourage du terrain
qu'est ce qui fait qu'un parti est
vivant c'est qu'il est vivant dans les
territoires qu'il sent qu'il est présent
avec de nombreux élus dans les villes
dans les régions dans les départements
ce n'est pas le cas dans marche n'est
pas le cas du rassemblement national
et pourtant les sondages nous vendre une
affiche en 2022 entre emmanuel macron et
marine le pen tous deux n'ont aucun
parti ils ont un parti médiatique
les républicains ont une chance c'est un
parti qui existe que les français
connaissent
ils ont un rapport concret avec des élus
de ce bord là quotidiennement que ce
soit à tout niveau de la république
donc il ya la carte à jouer importante
et on a l'impression qu'il veut le faire
en fait est à la mode c'est à dire faire
un parti médiatique et donc trouver quel
sera le candidat le plus médiatique
c'est une erreur une grave erreur qui
pourrait conduire à une défaite évidente
parce que quelle sera la différence
entre un candidat médiatique aura le
même projet puisqu'une ya une programme
qui modèlent macron qui va inventer un
projet sans doute deux mois avant
l'échéance puisque à l'avancé il sera
occupé par la présidence de l'union
européenne
d'autant que l'un d'entre eux qui est un
homme de terrain alors comme certains
autres évidemment à laurent wauquiez
valérie pécresse notamment favier
bertrand lui semble tenir la corde
il va mais qu'on nous citer un sondage
tout à l'heure on va jeter un oeil parce
que même si les sondages se trompent
souvent surtout en ce moment ils peuvent
quand même être intéressant regardez
d'après l'institut de sondages ifop
xavier bertrand pourrait largement
battre marine le pen et même emmanuel
macron chiffres d'intentions de vote au
deuxième tour on voit clairement que
xavier bertrand l'emporterait en quatre
points de plus qu emmanuel macron et la
deuxième tour dans le cas d'un xavier
bertrand le pen
xavier bertrand écraserait marine le pen
clairement alain houpert ça veut dire
quelque chose aux ce type de sondage
pour vous vous ne les prenez pas au
sérieux la droite aujourd'hui n'at-elle
pas un candidat naturel comme le dit
guillaume pelletier concernant les
sondages comme l'a dit monsieur poulin
on a vu ce que ça donnait comme vous
l'avez dit avec les élections régionales
ils se sont complètement trompés après
ses brillants pardon mais il a
brillamment élections régionales aussi
des pressions mais les sondages disaient
que nous allions avoir trois régions
sous la gouvernance du front national
c'est assez
ça a été un échec pour le front national
ça a été un échec pour la république en
marche
la france est à droite et au centre il
nous faut un candidat de la droite et du
centre et nous sommes capables de
décider nous mêmes comme l'a dit
monsieur poulat entre nous comme on dit
à la campagne on lave son linge
sale en famille on discute en famille on
est capable de décider nous mêmes quel
sera le candidat ça peut être monsieur
bertrand ça pète monsieur wauquiez ça
peut être madame pécresse être monsieur
s ça peut être beaucoup beaucoup de
personnes et nous avons nous avons un
homme une homme de stature qui s'appelle
nicolas sarkozy qu'on devrait consulter
pour qu'il voie les candidats qui les
auditionne et puis je pense que nicolas
sarkozy sera peut-être la personne a
auditionné pour qu on puisse débattre
entre nous en famille et décider entre
nous en famille sera le candidat à la
présidentielle le candidat de la droite
et du centre
alors à défaut de nicolas sarkozy à l'un
de ses proches ans s'est déjà exprimé
sur le sujet brice hortefeux le député
européen a l'air proche de l'ancien
président il n'est pas d'ailleurs du
tout sur la ligne 2 de guillaume
pelletier et coûté l'élection
présidentielle ne doit pas être une
démarche solitaire mais un élan
solidaire
il n'y a pas de candidat naturel il faut
qu'il y ait un système pour choisir et
qu'on se rassemble
je souhaite que xavier bertrand
participent au processus de sélection
car il n'y a pas de candidat
autoproclamé yves d'amécourt vous êtes
d'accord avec ce diagnostic de brice
hortefeux d'élection présidentielle ne
doit pas être une démarche solidaire
solitaire par don solidaire elle devrait
l'être justement là-dessus ce révélateur
emmanuel macron était bien solitaire et
ça lui a plutôt réussi au départ en tout
cas en fait emmanuel macron a été élu
non pas à cause des primaires de la
droite et de la gauche il a été lu à
cause de deux du buzz médiatique qui a
été organisée autour de françois fillon
et qui a finalement empêché françois
fillon de d'être qualifiés au deuxième
tour parce que tous les sondages
d'aujourd'hui sont très bien il donne
xavier bertrand gagnant au 2e tour ils
donnent tous les candidats gagnants au
deuxième tour le problème c'est pas
tellement d'être gagnant au 2e tour
c'est d'être qualifié au deuxième tour
et donc c'est pour ça qu'on a le souci
parce que si on avait pas d'inquiétude
sur la qualification de l'un de nos
candidats le premier tour se servirait
des primaires comme ça a été le cas à
l'époque entre entre chaban et giscard
d'estaing comme ça a été le cas pour
michel debré est comme ça a été le cas
aussi entre eux raymond barre et jacques
chirac comme ça a été le cas entre
edouard balladur et jacques chirac
le problème c'est que le premier tour ne
sert plus aujourd'hui de deux primaires
puisque il y a trois partis qui sont en
capacité d'aller au second tour et donc
il faut trouver une solution alors vous
savez quand on élit le pape ont réuni
les cardinaux et puis on fait un
conclave et puis à la fin personne ne
conteste l'élection du pape
moi ce que je reproche à notre famille
politique c'est que on est à huit mois
de l'élection présidentielle mais rien
n'a été organisé et donc on est en train
d'appliquer le précepte d'henri queuille
qui était un ministre de la cohésion de
la quatrième république qui disait je ne
connais pas de problème qu'une absence
de solution ne finisse par résoudre mais
le problème c'est que c'est pas comme ça
qu'on gagne une élection il faut
s'organiser
on a besoin d'avoir un projet un projet
solide un agenda de gouvernement on
apprend on a des gens qui sont très
intéressés par cette élection d'ailleurs
qui sont intéressés beaucoup plus par
élection présidentielle que par
élections régionales parce que quand on
questionne les gens il ya beaucoup de
gens qui sont pas venus voter aux
élections régionales mais qu'ils disent
mais qui nous ont dit on viendra voter
aux élections présidentielles donc
méfions nous des résultats des élections
régionales et n'en faisons pas une une
prévision de l'élection présidentielle
la question de la primaire des mises à
droite mais également à gauche puisqu'il
n'y a pas de de grandes primaires
ouvertes pour désigner un candidat
commun à la gauche une primaire a
annoncé d'ailleurs pour les écolos un
projet serait en préparation au ps
clairement alexis poulain c'est un sujet
sensible secteur de deux divisions la
mise en place d'une primaire dans un
parti politique
oui évidemment on va regarder et macro
ont réussi son coup parce qu'il refuse
tout primaire finalement et à gauche et
à droite puisque à l'époque qu'il était
demi de gauche ni de droite
donc c'est très facile de dire à partir
du moment où on a
une vague médiatique qui vous pousse
très facilement vers l'élection
présidentielle de s'affranchir
finalement de cette démocratie interne
résultat des courses il la démocratie a
souffert regardez la façon dont a été
traité le parlement france sous ce
quinquennat
donc il est important aussi que les
projets politiques prime d'abord sur sur
les personnalités sur la guerre des ego
celle qu'on veut vendre et à gauche
c'est clairement ça aujourd'hui on voit
bien yannick jadot contrarier un d'aller
à une primaire à gauche jean luc
mélenchon qui a décidé d'y aller seul de
toute façon et puis suivra qui veut
derrière le leader de la france
insoumise et puis au ps on attend de
voir alors carole delga vient de sortir
parce qu'elle a gagné une région mais ça
ne veut rien dire en réalité le ps à
bien des idées sur de potentiels
candidats mais à huit mois d'une
présidentielle encore une fois je trouve
que c'est un peu tard pour s'organiser
quand on est un grand parti structuré et
c'est cette précipitation à cette
précipitation qui joue d'abord le jeu du
temps médiatique plutôt que je du temps
politique que je critique parce que ce
que veulent les français je crois
et pourquoi ils se désintéressent
finalement des désirs des taux
d'abstention important devrait dire une
chose c'est qu'ils attendent des
politiques de rupture c'est ça suffit
cette politique finalement qui mêle
macron incarne absolument qui est celle
qui n'a pas changé un d'essayer de faire
des réformes qui n'aboutit jamais de
continuer dans une intégration
européenne perpétuel et finalement de ne
rien changer pour tout changer non je
crois qu'aujourd'hui il ya des retraits
débat d'ailleurs cette candidature
surprise qui n'en est pas une puisque il
ne s'est pas déclarée mais génération et
nous qui colle des affiches pour
l'eczéma qui essayent de pousser le
débat justement vers des sujets plus
clivants plus délicat c'est ça qui
attend les français un vrai débat de
fond sur qu'est ce qu'on attend
qu'est-ce qui va attendre ce pays la
france dans les cinq les 10 prochaines
années si on ne fait rien si on ne
change rien alors rien ne va changer
évidemment
or est-ce qu'on veut continuer
l'intégration européenne est ce qu on
veut continuer les politiques
migratoires telles qu'elles sont est-ce
qu'on veut continuer les politiques de
l'emploi subventionné ou pas alors que
ça ne fonctionne pas est ce que l'on
veut continuer de faire semblant
sur l'insécurité la sécurité avec des
politiques là encore qui sont des
rustines ou des politiques médiatiques
dont je crois qu'aujourd'hui les sujets
importants ne sont pas abordés ils sont
toujours évité de manière tabou et mener
le maquereau est passé maître en la
matière puisqu'il dit tout et son
contraire d'une semaine sur l'autre donc
c'est très facile
c'est scandaleux c'est scandaleux de
faire ça en réalité aujourd'hui on
demande à responsables politiques de se
positionner peut dire ce qu'il pense et
de dire ce qu'il va faire pour résoudre
les problèmes des français donc c'est ça
si une primaire il doit avoir alors
elles doivent être des primaires
programmatique d'idées de débats d'idées
et surtout de projets de concret c'est à
dire voilà ce que je vais proposer ces
six avaient fait françois fillon avec
c'était le seul à avoir un vrai
programme écrit concertée il ya l'avenir
en commun également de jean luc
mélenchon ou là des gens travaillent sur
un programme aujourd'hui on a
l'impression que c'est j'y vais parce
que bas les français même bien donc je
vais y aller non c'est pas ça la
politique
et c'est certainement parce que les
français at on alors on perd le mot de
la fin pour vous puisque on le disait en
ce début de débat vous serez demain
matin présence au bureau politique des
républicains vous allez taper du poing
sur la table à votre niveau
qu'est ce que vous allez leur dire je
veux dire que l'élection présidentielle
le principe de condorcet je préfère un
terrain intel et il ya deux candidats au
deuxième tour
c'est pas une triangulaire ces deux
candidats il y aura le front national et
je veux que le candidat contre le front
national
ce soit un candidat de la droite et du
centre est pas emmanuel macron parce que
nous nous battons depuis quatre ans
contre emmanuel macron il serait injuste
comme l'a dit monsieur poulin qu'il soit
à nouveau président de la république
merci en tout cas à tous les trois alain
houpert avec six poulains yves
d'amécourt d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt pour france les suit donc
demain on en saura peut-être un peu plus
après cette réunion et ce bureau
politique merci à vous dans quelques
instants rester avec nous nous partirons
aux états unis si joe biden a pris la
parole hier lors de la fête nationale la
question de l'ouverture des frontières
n'a pas été évoqué pour l'heure les
règles d'accès au territoire américain
reste donc inchangé
et puis nous parlerons du royaume uni
promesses du brick city durci le ton sur
sa politique d'immigration
[Musique]
vous
vous allez vous vous consacrez au
festival du film russe à paris qui est
intitulé quand les russes nous
bouleverse nous bouleverse toujours vous
savez parce qu'on les comprend pas il
nous touche
ils nous font pleurer et on sait pas
pourquoi l'objectif réel profond que
vous avez là c'est quoi c'est de faire
de la pédagogie c'est de faire mieux que
ça c'est de recréer des liens que la
politique n'arrive plus à rome alors
c'est à dire que la culture c'est au
dessus de tout ça le cinéma nous dit des
vérités que nous disent personne ni les
politiques ni les ambassadeurs ni les
journalistes et nous sommes prêts c'est
la même culture c'est la même façon de
penser
les mêmes physique je pense qu'il ya une
union qui va se rétablir c'est pas
possible autrement
et de toute façon ils ont besoin de nous
comme nous avons besoin d'eux je suis
optimiste
peut-être pas tout de suite il faut
passer au delà de quelques quelques
obstacles mais je crois que l'avenir est
allemand
[Musique]
au carrefour d'une pollution insultes et
d'une nécessité technologique absolue
les terres rares sont au coeur des défis
du 21e siècle c'est un enjeu stratégique
pour tous les pays puisque leur accès
est aujourd'hui principalement chinois
en l'état actuel des capacités minières
connu la part chinoise et réserve
mondiale est de l'ordre de 37 % dans la
cadre de la guerre commerciale avec les
états unis la chine utilise sa position
comme levier de négociations mais il est
clair qu'avec les pénuries et les
tensions que nous allons connaître sur
certaines terreur il faut envisager
d'autres solutions
[Musique]
l'idée c'est que lorsque les cellules de
la rétine ne sont plus capables de
répondre à la lumière puisqu'elles ont
dégénéré de rendre ces cellules
sensibles à la lumière nous sommes
inspirés d'une découverte qui avaient
été faites par des gens qui
travaillaient sur les algues avaient
identifié chez les algues des protéines
qui répondent à la lumière et entraîne
la formation d'un courant électrique
comme le font les neurones et comme le
feront normalement les cellules
sensibles à la lumière dans la rétine
pas ce qu'il va dire qu'il voit un pc il
distingue la lumière il distingue quoi
exactement
alors le patient et que le pain par
exemple de reconnaître les passages
protégés dans la rue de détecter des
objets différents objets de petite
taille de grande taille plusieurs
niveaux de pompage de les compter de les
attraper
mais comme c'est un patient qui ne
voyait plus rien depuis une quinzaine
d'années c'est déjà une source d'espoir
c'est évidemment pas un point définitif
du parcours c'est un une étape franchie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vingt ans
soyez les bienvenus en direct sur rt
france si vous nous rejoignez aux états
unis malgré un taux de vaccination en
hausse et une situation sanitaire qui
s'améliorent globalement toujours pas de
perspectives pour une réouverture des
frontières américaines pour plus de
précisions nous retrouvons tout de suite
notre reporter thomas bonnet en direct
de washington bonsoir thomas quelles
sont les dernières informations sur le
sujet
bonsoir stéphanie bel et bien finalement
très peu d'informations si bien que
certains on a l'impression ont
l'impression que ce sujet est un peu
délaissé par le gouvernement américain
parce qu'il ya d'abord donc ses
frontières terrestres des états unis
donc avec le canada et avec le mexique
des frontières qui sont toujours fermés
depuis le mois de mars 2020 depuis le
tout début de cette pandémie ça fait
donc 16 mois rendez vous compte seize
mois que ces frontières sont fermées
avec seulement quelques allègements par
exemple ce lundi côté canadien il ya un
allègement puisque maintenant les
autorités canadiennes ne réclame plus la
mise en 14 n des citoyens canadiens
vaccinés qui rentrent sur le territoire
c'est un tout petit pas puisqu'en
réalité les voyages non essentiels sont
toujours interdits pour les citoyens
canadiens notamment en direction donc à
des états unis cette fermeture de
frontières a énormément de conséquence
d'abord des conséquences pour les
personnes qui ont de la famille de part
et d'autre de ses frontières que ce soit
donc entre les états unis le canada ou
entre les etats-unis et le mexique et
puis un impact économique assez
gigantesque par exemple chaque mois où
cette frontière est fermée entre les
etats-unis et le canada se sont un
milliard et demi de dollars de pertes
pour le côté américain et pour le côté
canadien en 2019 20 sur les 22 millions
de touristes qui sont entrés au canada
15 millions étaient américains ce qui
vous donne un ordre d'idée du manque à
gagner pour le secteur du tourisme au
canada
alors malgré la pression d'un certain
nombre d'élus d'un certain nombre
d'acteurs économiques sur leurs
gouvernements respectifs
aucun accord n'a pu être trouvé pour le
moment entre les autorités américaines
et canadiennes ce qui fait que c'est le
statu quo la frontière sera toujours
fermés au moins jusqu'au 21 juillet
prochain
et en ce qui concerne l'europe un thomas
à présent les voyageurs américains ils
sont autorisés à voyager mais alors
petit un jeu steve tout de même ça et
nous expliquer pourquoi est-ce qu'on se
demande l'un vers ce n'est toujours pas
possible
et non ceux des familles pas de
réciprocité effectivement les citoyens
américains ont l'autorisation de venir
en europe depuis quelques semaines
depuis le mois de juin mais linverse est
toujours pas possible alors on avait
attendu des annonces lors du voyage de
joe biden en europe lors du sommet du g7
rien lors du sommet de l'union
européenne à rien non plus alors
certains se disaient que peut-être que
le président américain allait profiter
de son allocution pour la fête nationale
américaine qui avait lieu hier pour
faire des annonces en ce sens mais là
encore rien aucune allusion à la
réouverture pro possible des frontières
on reste encore sur un statu quo ce
qu'on sait c'est qu'il y à des groupes
de travail qui sont qui se réunissent le
temps en temps avec donc des
représentants américains des
représentants de l'union européenne pour
tenter de trouver une solution trouver
un accord mais pour le moment force est
de constater qu'il n'y a toujours rien
alors on se raccroche aux quelques
déclarations des officiels américains
prenez l'exemple d' anthony blinken qui
était en france il y a quelques jours et
voici ce qu'il a déclaré il faut que
nous soyons guidé par par la science par
les experts
dans le domaine médical et ne pas
prendre une décision politique prendre
une décision basée sur sur l'effet sur
les données j'espère que ça se fera très
rapidement on en a très envie mais
j'espère que ce sera dans dans les
semaines à venir parler moi vous l'avez
entendu l'optimisme du secrétaire d'état
anthony blinken qui parle donc de
quelques semaines mais en réalité on ne
sait pas vraiment quelle sera l'issue
et quand ses frontières vont pouvoir
ouvrir en tout cas ce que je peux vous
dire c'est qu'un certain nombre
d'acteurs économiques du secteur du
tourisme ont déjà fait une croix sur
cette saison le deuxième été consécutif
sans touristes étrangers on imagine là
aussi l'impact économique pour eux et
donc il ya aussi une inquiétude parce
que les videmment de la situation vous
l'avez entendu de la part d' anthony
blinken est étroitement liée à celle de
la probable propagation du colis de 19
et il ya donc ce variant delta et je
peux vous dire que la situation
européenne essuyé suit avec attention
par les autorités américaines et 2 cette
situation en europe dépend certainement
l'ouverture possible des frontières pour
les voyageurs européens à destination
des états unis
merci thomas bonnet en direct de
washington
et justement ce delta on en parle
puisque de nombreux pays s'inquiètent
d'une reprise épidémique notamment la
russie en cause notamment
on en parlait la forte circulation de ce
variant delta du corona virus face à
cette nouvelle vague moscou lance une
campagne de vaccination proposant une
troisième injection pour renforcer la
correspondance de vera goffman plus de 3
millions de moscovites ont déjà reçu au
moins une dose du vaccin a déclaré le
maire de la capitale sergueï sobianine
il vient d'inaugurer un nouveau centre
de vaccination capable d'accueillir plus
de 6000 personnes par jour pour servier
ce bénigne il est crucial de se protéger
contre la pandémie qui s'accélère je
vous propose d'écouter ses one year
aujourd'hui nous avons atteint la barre
des 3 groupes de personnes qui ont reçu
la première dose du vaccin important
pour se protéger contre la pandémie qui
s'accélère je suis très reconnaissant
envers les habitants de moscou qui se
sont montrés responsables par rapport à
leur santé et celle de leurs proches
aujourd'hui nous avons un des plus
grands centres de vaccination d'europe
et le plus grand de russie capacité
standard de ce sens est de 6000
personnes par jour dans le cas d'un
afflux plus important il sera tout à
fait possible de prolonger les heures
d'ouverture et sa capacité augmentera en
conséquence toute une équipe de médecins
d'infirmiers d'employés de centre
multifonctionnel de service public et de
bénévoles a été constitué afin d'assurer
une vaccination rapide et confortable à
ceux qui souhaitent venir ici malgré la
hausse du nombre des contaminations les
autorités n'envisage toujours pas de
confinement mais appelle la population à
se faire vacciner le plus vite possible
afin d'éviter le retour aux restrictions
les plus drastiques plus de 24000 de
nouveaux cas de coronavirus ont été
détectés a aussi à dernières 24 heures
dont plus de 6500 à moscou et qu'en est
il du continent africain l'om est tire
désormais la sonnette d'alarmé le nombre
de cas sur le continent connaît une
progression constante sur six semaines
consécutives avec notamment une hausse
de 25% le
sénégal s'échappe n'échappe pas à cette
hausse du taux de contamination
les précisions de notre correspondante à
dakar les la fameuse au même si la cour
des décès restent encore maîtrisable
force est de constater que le corona
virus gagne du terrain
ici au sénégal avec notamment une
propagation galopante de quatre
variantes dont le variant delta qui
préoccupent tout particulièrement ici
plus contagieux plus agressif il a déjà
été signalé dans 16 pays africains et le
sénégal n'y échappe pas alors plusieurs
causes à cette hausse des contaminations
la fin de l'état d'urgence les
rassemblements populaires ou encore la
reprise des activités et puis un élément
à prendre en compte ici nous sommes
entrés dans la saison des pluies où les
températures peuvent atteindre les 45
degrés ce qui rend le port du masque
très minoritaires comme on a pu le
constater dans les rues dakaroise le
masque faut le dire c'est un peu gênant
parce que ça a étouffé tout ça avec la
chaleur la console quand on bloque aussi
les masses
sa sainteté et du coup on est obligé
d'enlever d'enlever on a constaté que
il y en a pas assez de deux ans qu'ils
respectent manal masque mais je me suis
dit non seulement les respecter les
mesures barrières
ça ne suffit pas tout simplement le
masque il faut d'abord il faudrait
d'abord en tout cas de désengagement
personnel et parce que chacun d'entre
nous ne vous ne veut pas être athée en
tout cas sa maladie l'a donc il ya pire
nous ne devons pas du tout simplement à
la peur des masques les habitants la
population sénégalaise non respectueux
les mesures à savoir les masques les
distances ils ne respectent plus à la
hausse
ils disent que ça étouffe il nous dit
alors que les masques nous protège face
à cette flambée des nouveaux cas le
comité national de gestion des épidémies
a convoqué une réunion en urgence pour
évaluer la stratégie mise en place
jusqu'à présent et préparer la riposte
notamment à travers la vaccination elle
reste à convaincre une population qui se
montrent majoritairement méfiante
vis-à-vis des vaccins
rappelons ce chiffre de la msa ce jour
15 millions de personnes sont vaccinées
sur le continent ce qui représente à
peine 1,2 pour cent de la population
africaine
369 migrants secourues la nuit dernière
en méditerranée par l'ofen vikings
sixième opération de sauvetage en
quelques jours du navire de
l'association sos méditerranée 572
rescapés sont actuellement à bord hier
après midi le navire était déjà venu en
aide à 71 exilé en péril sur une
embarcation en bois
les nations unies ont récemment épinglé
la libye et l'union européenne demandant
qu'une réforme des opérations de
sauvetage et la question migratoire
sujet de confrontation entre paris et
rome entre 2018 et 2019 la france et
l'italie qui est celle aujourd'hui une
réconciliation rencontre de l'apaisement
la mi-journée l'elysée donc entre les
présidents sert diomat arena et emmanuel
macron disant qu'un chef d'état
transalpin n'était pas venu en visite
officielle à paris
les deux hommes ont affirmé leur volonté
de conclure rapidement un traité pour
renforcer les relations bilatérales et
acter une vision commune de l'avenir de
l'europe notamment au travers de la
jeunesse aujourd'hui nous souhaitons
renforcer de manière décisive ce socle
commun le structurer en faire un ciment
de l'intégration européenne
c'est dans cet esprit que nous avons ici
confirmer notre volonté d'aboutir au
plus vite au traité de coopération
bilatérale renforcée et ceux traités
dits du quirinal nous permettra de
consolider cette relation d'offrir aussi
à nos peuples et nos jeunesse de vraies
perspectives ainsi souhaitons nous que
les jeunesses de nos deux pays
s'engagent ensemble à travers un service
civique franco-italien qui leur
permettra de renforcer sur le terrain et
de manière très concrète cette amitié
ces valeurs qui nous lie je suis heureux
d'annoncer que d'étaler
favorablement accueilli la proposition
que nos deux pays
accueillis pour un service civique
commun franco italien nos jeunes ne
pourront collaborer ensemble nos
administrations sont prêtes à définir
rapidement les modalités et les
mécanismes de ce service civique commun
non je ne vont collaborer ensemble vont
échanger des expériences vont agir en
commun trait sur les questions
migratoires le royaume uni lui reprend
la main avec le durcissement du système
d'asile une promesse du break site
annoncée en mars dernier et remis sur la
table ce week-end à commencer par une
hausse des peines de prison pour les
migrants traversant illégalement la
manche mais aussi pour leurs passeurs
cyrielle l'abbé david hess bulbul en 236
migrants secourues dans la manche depuis
ce vendredi une opération quasi
quotidiennes dans les eaux britanniques
et pour lutter contre ce phénomène
londres s'apprête à augmenter les peines
de prison de migrants et passeur ainsi
un réfugié ayant traversé la manche il
également en cours à quatre ans de
prison contre six mois actuellement
la personne qui organisera son passage
risquera elle la prison à vie contre 14
ans d'emprisonnement pour le moment un
projet de durcissement du système
d'asile britannique considéré comme
débordés par les autorités depuis le
début de l'année 2021
plus de 6000 personnes ont traversé la
manche à bord de petites embarcations
un record à titre de comparaison en 2020
le total de traverser sur l'année
s'élevaient à 8500
ce week end priti patel ministre de
l'intérieur britannique a décrit un
projet juste mais ferme visant à
décourager l'immigration illégale
il est très vraisemblable que ceux qui
se rendent au royaume uni à bord de
petites embarcations viennent d'un pays
sur de l'union européenne où il aurait
pu demander l'asile quand c'est le cas
ils ne cherchent pas le premier endroit
possible où se réfugier mais font du
shopping en choisissant le royaume uni
comme destination préférée à d'autres en
utilisant des voies illégales pour s'y
rendre pour les progrès qu site le
durcissement des conditions
d'immigration était un enjeu primordial
la réforme du système d'asile prévoient
de ne plus accorder les mêmes droits aux
personnes selon qu'elles soient entrés
légalement ou illégalement dans le pays
quant à ceux dont la demande est
examinée puis refusé ils seront expulsés
rapidement du royaume uni et pour en
parler nous sommes avec l'autre
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir que claude l'os
maison merci d'être avec nous comme
d'habitude on va essayer d'approfondir
un sujet et de le décrypter alors
pourquoi n'y at il rien sur
l'immigration dans les cordes de retrait
conclu entre l'union européenne et le
royaume uni on voit à quel point c'est
un sujet majeur parce que toute la
campagne du bric site a été fondé sur
l'idée que le royaume uni voulait
récupérer le contrôle national de ses
frontières et qu' ils voulaient rejeté
aussi l'immigration alors cela dit vous
avez bien fait la distinction entre
l'immigration légale et l'immigration
illégale et
il y avait en grande bretagne près de 5
millions de travailleurs tout à fait
légaux ayant un travail à un métier
parmi eux un million trois cent mille
son parti inquiet sur la situation post
break site sur leur situation
personnelle
il en reste un peu plus de 3 millions
qui devaient se faire enregistrer avant
le 1er juillet donc la semaine dernière
pour avoir le droit à un permis de
travail en grande bretagne donc à
travers des des inscriptions assez
complexe sur le plan administratif mais
évidemment le royaume uni l'économie
britannique a besoin de travailleurs
qualifiés qui entrent légalement royaume
uni et pour cela elle a établi des
critères pour pouvoir chez revenir au
royaume uni et avoir un permis de
travail et bien il faut d'abord avoir un
contrat de travail que ce contrat de
travail peut qu'on perd contre n 1 c'est
un conte prennent un salaire
suffisamment élevé pour pouvoir subvenir
à ses besoins démontrer qu'on parle
anglais qu'on a des qualifications
professionnelles requises
donc c'est une immigration choisie pour
le reste pour l'immigration illégale
eh bien vous avez très bien décrit ce
que dit le ministre de l'intérieur
madame pop rithy panh à vrai dire
at-elle qui effectivement a dit hier je
crois que elle rendrait la manche
impraticable pour les petites
embarcations
et pour ce faire elle a nommé un ancien
commandant de marine pour s'occuper
d'eux précisément de ce problème et donc
on peut penser que effectivement ce sera
efficace
ça veut dire que pendant un certain
temps eh bien c'est la france qui va
devoir s'occuper de ses candidats à
l'exil au royaume uni parce que ils ont
de bonnes raisons de vouloir aller au
royaume uni soit ils ont déjà de la
famille soit elles viennent d'un pays
anglophones africains par exemple soit
il considère que finalement ils pourront
s'intégrer relativement facilement dans
cette société
alors maintenant c'est fini on ferme la
frontière et donc pendant un certain
temps il va probablement y avoir un
afflux de ce genre de réfugiés du côté
de calais on avait renforcé
considérablement les forces policières
pour traiter ce problème mais il est
vraisemblable que vu les signaux qui
sont envoyées depuis londres la
discussion va s'exercer et que très
rapidement il y aura moins de candidats
à aller en grande bretagne et ils ne
font que traverser la france et viennent
de beaucoup plus loin
ils sont entrés dans l'union européenne
en effet dans un autre pays mais qui
n'est pas à la france la france n'est
qu'un un lieu de transit est un lieu de
passage et ceci pose donc un problème à
gérer et qui est un problème qui est une
conséquence du bric site clos de
blanchemaison y at il une tout autre
sujet de préoccupation dans le sillage
du bric site y en a beaucoup
évidemment il ya la pêche est juste
avant pâques on a vu que les pêcheurs
méditerranée les pêcheurs parlant de
normandie en france ne se voyait plus
reconnaître leurs droits traditionnels
dans les eaux de jersey que le traité de
granville n'était pas reconnue par les
accords du bric site est finalement plus
généralement sur les problèmes de pêche
nos pêcheurs se plaignent que les
licences qui devrait leur être accordées
ne le sont pas dans les conditions
conformes aux traités qu'on réduit leurs
droits de pêche peut quelquefois on leur
contestent leurs droits de pêche dans
les eaux britanniques alors que pendant
une période de transition assez longue
et doivent être
ils ont été reconnus par le traité et
puis deuxième sujet peut-être
politiquement encore plus important
c'est le
j'ai de l'annex irlande au traité de
break fit que monsieur boris johnson n'a
pas l'intention de respecter
alors il ya eu des incidents là aussi
juste avant pas que pour l'anniversaire
de l'accord du vendredi saint qui
prévoyait l'accord entre les là
l'irlande du nord et les autres
participants de façon à ce qu'il n'y ait
plus de frontières entre l'irlande du
nord parti du royaume uni et la
république d'irlande est l'objet
précisément de cette annexe à l'accord
du rexy qu'on appelle l' annexe irlande
c'est qu'il n'y ait pas de
rétablissement des frontières physiques
ni pour les personnes ni pour les
marchandises et pour cela on a inventé
un dispositif assez ingénieux qui
consiste à ce que les fraudes et les
contrôles sanitaires douaniers produits
d'origine et lieu dans les ports
britanniques éventuellement dans les
ports d'irlande du nord et pas à la
limite entre l'irlande du nord et la
république d'irlande
mais laury johnson évidemment a fort à
faire avec les ses partisans les plus
nationalistes qui ne veulent pas de ces
contrôles à l'intérieur du royaume uni
et pour le moment on a reporté
l'échéance on vit dans une période de
transition qui ne doit pas durer
longtemps parce que ça veut dire il ya
une brèche dans le marché unique
européen et que des produits des animaux
des moutons néo zélandais pourrait
pénétrer sur le territoire du marché
unique en passant par l'irlande du nord
on l'a appris d'ailleurs aujourd'hui une
plutôt bonne nouvelle pour londres après
ce break site long qui est à nouveau le
premier centre financier en europe pour
les échanges d'actions ça vous étonne
pardonnez moi mais pas du tout parce que
ce petit jeu entre amsterdam et londres
en fait amsterdam était devenue la
première place financière pour les
échanges d'actions en bourse au début de
l'année après le break site parce que 6
milliards d'activité s'était déplacé de
londres vers le continent principalement
en effet vers amsterdam et ce qui s'est
passé ces jours ci
c'est que le royaume uni grande bretagne
a conclu un accord avec la suisse
alors que la suisse a toujours un
contentieux avec l'union européenne la
grande-bretagne qui n'est plus dans
l'union européenne a pu conclure cet
accord avec la suisse et par conséquent
la suisse a rétabli et échanges
d'actions suisse sud à la bourse de
londres
et cet afflux d'affaires a fait passer
très légèrement d'ailleurs le volume
d'affaires de londres devant celui
d'amsterdam
mais d'ici quelques mois il est probable
que le contentieux qui est un
contentieux global entre l'union
européenne et la suisse saura trouver
les solutions et que l'activité des
échanges et des actions suisse reprendra
dans toutes les bourses européennes et
se répartira à travers les diverses
bourse suivant la l'attrait qu'elle
exerce sur les différents opérateurs
alors justement cet attrait fait l'objet
d'un débat politique parce que le
ministre des finances britannique a dit
récemment qu'il allait prendre des
mesures pour rendre la bourse de londres
beaucoup plus attractive que les autres
bourthes en facilitant notamment
l'inscription à la bourse de londres
d'entreprises qui sont dans les
nouvelles technologies et la directrice
générale de la bourse de londres a
enchéri mais avec une clause de prudence
en disant qu'on ait fait tout serait
fait pour faciliter l'accès des
entreprises à la bourse de londres
par conséquent pour récupérer des
capitaux pour financer leurs activités
mais que la bourse de londres voulait
respecter les normes des normes strictes
des normes qui sont qui ont surtout en
vigueur sur le plan international et
notamment à l'intérieur de l'europe
autrement dit la menace qui planait dont
on a souvent parlé d'un singapour sur la
table y est à dire de mesures
extrêmement laxiste vis-à-vis des
entreprises vis-à-vis des opérateurs
financiers
eh bien ce n'est pas pour demain car ce
n'est pas l'intérêt des acteurs
britanniques ça n'est pas l'intérêt de
la cité de passer pour un lieu permissif
où on peut faire un peu tout et
n'importe quoi comme cela est le cas sur
certaines places financières asiatiques
merci claude blanche raison d'avoir été
avec mon direct sur rt france est resté
avec nous dans quelques instants nous
parlerons de la vaccination obligatoire
le débat est clairement lancé en france
les consultations aussi notamment en ce
qui concerne les soignants alors que le
variant delta poursuit sa progression et
puis direction le royaume uni où le port
du masque ne sera plus obligatoire dans
les lieux publics clos à partir du 19
juillet annonce du premier ministre
britannique
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les libéraux l'uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï tg les gens ne
s'étaient des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas un oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
la grande bretagne a donc eu cinq ans
pour se préparer
cinq ans de psychodrame 50 négociations
politiques
est-ce qu'elle était prête je 31
décembre pour redevenir une île réponse
par du moment où le royaume uni avait
décidé de quitter l'union européenne il
ne pouvait plus continuer de bénéficier
de ses droits équivalents à si vous êtes
dans l'europe pas dans l'europe
vis-à-vis des 27 est à autre c'est juste
quelque chose d'inconcevable
l'angleterre 20 perd gros là nos amis
britanniques ont fait un choix en 2016
qui est un choix qui je pense va
impacter l'économie profondément sur les
prochaines années et va impacter des
générations les choses sont en train de
se caler de se mettre en place
est ce que les choses sont totalement
fluide réponse est non
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
vous allez vous vous consacrez au
festival du film russe à paris qui est
intitulé quand les russes nous
bouleverse et nous bouleverse toujours
vous savez parce qu'on les comprend pas
il nous touche
ils nous font pleurer et on sait pas
pourquoi l'objectif réel profond que
vous avez là c'est quoi c'est de faire
de la pédagogie c'est de faire mieux que
ça c'est de recréer des liens que la
politique n'arrive plus à rome alors
c'est à dire que la culture c'est au
dessus de tout ça le cinéma nous dit des
vérités que nous disent personne ni les
politiques ni les ambassadeurs ni les
journalistes et nous craignent
c'est la même culture c'est la même
façon de penser
les mêmes physique je pense qu'il ya une
union qui va se rétablir c'est pas
possible autrement
et de toute façon ils ont besoin de nous
comme nous avons besoin d'eux je suis
optimiste
tout est pas tout de suite il faut
passer au delà de quelques quelques
obstacles mais je crois que l'avenir est
allemand
[Musique]
ses accusations elle pose quand même la
question du traitement des dissidents
par votre mouvement c'est des
accusations politiques qui n'ont rien à
voir avec allégations portées devant la
justice espagnole
nous n'avons jamais expulsé ni les
organisations des droits de l'homme ni
la presse alors que le maroc les occuper
aujourd'hui sont fermés est-ce que
désormais il ya un risque de voir
s'installer un conflit militaire sur la
durée les lignes rouges sont déjà
franchi qu'on a guère a commencé après
que le maroc a annexé encore et partie
de notre territoire nous avons accepté
un plan de paix qui consiste à
l'organisation d'un référendum
d'intervention pour laisser les
sahraouis le choix de choisir le futur
de choisir entre l'indépendance et
l'intégration maroc à savoir que ce
n'est pas une partie du territoire
marocain
[Musique]
1 21h merci nous rejoindre pour cette
deuxième heure d'émission tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
sens en juillet il faut que l'obligation
vaccinale des soignants soient mises en
oeuvre déclaration ce matin d'un fischer
le monsieur vexin du gouvernement les
consultations sont lancés depuis
aujourd'hui autour de cette question
le medef et la cfdt s'en mêle et sont
favorables à la vaccination obligatoire
pour les salariés au contact du public
le variant delta qui continue sa
progression il est en passe de devenir
majoritaires en ile de france
outre-manche le port du masque ne sera
plus obligatoire dans les lieux publics
clos à partir du 19 juillet les
dernières restrictions liées au virus
devrait aussi être levés à cette date
annonce du premier ministre britannique
qui a tenu une conférence de presse tout
à l'heure des mesures controversées
malgré l'envolée des contaminations
attribués aux variants delta kovats dans
le viseur le président vénézuélien
nicolás maduro a lancé hier un ultimatum
au programme visant à garantir un accès
équitable au vaccin anti kobe 19
il est sûr que son pays à payer ses
doses mais ne les a toujours pas reçu
les européens aussi sous feu des
critiques sur ce mécanisme mondial alors
que le variant d'un change la donne sur
le continent africain jusqu'ici épargné
par la pandémie
[Musique]
la vaccination obligatoire pour le
personnel soignant doit je cite être
mises en place sont les mots ce matin
d'alain fischer le président du conseil
d'orientation de la stratégie vaccinale
contre le coc vie de 19
et ce alors que le ministre de la santé
mettant en garde contre une quatrième
vague épidémique possible dès la fin
juillet mass hydra magnan faut-il
obliger le personnel soignant à se faire
vacciner contre le coc vite 19
dans une tribune publiée hier dans le
jdd 96 médecins le demandent au
gouvernement pour éviter une quatrième
vague épidémique
parce que c'est un devoir éthique de
protection des personnes vulnérables
dont ils ont la charge tous les
soignants doivent être vaccinés
nous demandons au gouvernement de mettre
en oeuvre les dispositions nécessaires
pour que l'application de cette décision
soit effective avant le début du mois de
septembre
car au delà du personnel soignant la
campagne vaccinale est au ralenti en
france le nombre de rendez vous pour une
injection diminue en partie à cause des
vacances d'été concernant les soignants
selon la fédération hospitalière de
france leur taux de vaccination est de
57% dans les ehpad 64% à l'hôpital
l'exécutif insiste sur la nécessité de
se faire vacciner sans parler pour
l'instant d'obligations
demandez un soignant de se vacciner
c'est pas de pointer du doigt c'est pas
dénigrer le travail qui a été fait c'est
pas daigné le sens de leur engagement
c'est pas vouloir brusquer qui que ce
soit demandez à des soignants se
vacciner c'est leur demander d'aller au
bout leur engagement au service de leurs
malades et la santé des gens qui l'ont
choisi de protéger encore une fois la
vaccination obligatoire quand on est
soignants se sera pas une nouveauté les
syndicats commencent à s'en mêler la cgt
appelle au respect des soignants et
estime qu'il vaut mieux je cite
convaincre plutôt que contraindre
toujours dans le jdd deux hommes
habituellement opposés signe une tribune
commune laurent berger et geoffroy roux
de bézieux
les patrons respectivement de la cfdt et
du medef parle d'une même voix pour
encourager les salariés à se faire
vacciner
et il ne s'agit pas seulement d'une
question de santé publique mais aussi
d'une question économique
la vaccination est la seule manière de
retrouver une vie normale
la reprise économique la relance de
l'emploi ne pourront se faire qu'à la
condition d'une vaccination massive de
nos concitoyens une question qui devrait
être abordé avec emmanuel macron qui
reçoit les représentants patronaux et
syndicaux ce mardi à l'elysée
pour ce qui est des soignants le
gouvernement planche déjà sur un projet
de loi pour les obliger à se faire
vacciner
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
françois o merrill président cf cgc
bonsoir françois om-lille merci
d'être avec nous on vient d'entendre le
medef et la cfdt favorable à la
vaccination obligatoire pour les
salariés au contact du public cet appel
solennel est ce qu'il est légitime selon
vous est ce que ces syndicats sont dans
leur rôle
c'est pas tellement à moi de définir
très exactement quel est le rôle d'une
organisation syndicale en tant que tel
moi je je connais le mien je ne vais pas
critiquer les prises de position que
prenne mes collègues pour ce qui
concerne la cfe cgc le position
finalement elle est relativement simple
et elle est de 10 rebonds de deux choses
l'une soit il est nécessaire de rendre
la vaccination obligatoire pour des
raisons qu'on était un peu exposée à
dans votre reportage et des raisons qui
sont commentées par ailleurs et à ce
moment là le gouvernement doit le faire
c'est pas le seul vaccin qui serait
obligatoire il y en a d'autres mais
c'est pas à moi de dire s'il faut le
rendre obligatoire ou pas après par
ailleurs nous on est intervenu je suis
intervenu au nom de mon organisation sur
la question de la vaccination de façon à
travailler avec le gouvernement sur les
moyens à mettre en place pour rendre
pour faciliter la vaccination dans les
entreprises aujourd'hui il y a
on le sait la vaccination contre la
grippe qui fonctionne plutôt bien qu'ils
aient mis à disposition dans les
services de santé au travail
c'est un moyen assez pratique assez
efficace de d'augmenter le niveau de
vaccination sur tel ou tel sujet sur
telle ou telle maladie donc sur la
question de la vaccination contre le coc
vide tout ce qui peut être mis en oeuvre
pour faciliter cette vaccination dans le
cadre du travail
eh bien nous on soutient ces
dispositions là après pour répondre à
très précisément avec votre à votre
question
moi je n'ai pas à donner mon avis sur le
fait qu'il faut ou non la rendre
obligatoire
vous suivez alors ce que disent ces
syndicats tout de même ces voix là c'est
notre seule chance en substance un de
faire repartir l'économie et donc les
entreprises savent où partager tout de
même ce n'est à glo stick son ensemble
vous piéger et vous dire à ben vous
voyez vous voulez l'arn obligatoire mais
en gros on a une pente bien faire pour
l'économie est ce qu'on doit penser
ainsi
bah écoutez et là encore vous savez
c'est un sujet un peu délicate sur
lequel beaucoup de gens se sont exprimés
à plusieurs reprises en n'ayant pas
forcément les compétences nous nous dans
une organisation syndicale on n'a pas de
compétence précise iac d'experts sur les
questions sanitaires
ce que je sais c'est que la reprise
économique par contre effectivement et
là il faut la soutenir par tout un tas
de dispositions on à demain ce sommet à
l'elysée où effectivement on va aborder
un certain nombre de sujets qui sont
dans l'ordre du jour et qui sont
relatifs à la question du redémarrage
économique des moyens qu'il faut mettre
en place qui sont des moyens financiers
par ailleurs qui peuvent être des moyens
d'organisation de façon à porter la
reprise et c'est vrai qu'il serait
dommage moi juste d'accord avec ça il
serait dommage de de se retrouver
confronté à une quatrième vague une
troisième quatrième ou cinquième vague
moi j'ai fait confiance dans les
services sanitaires de mon pays j'espère
que ils font tout ce qu'il faut pour
justement l'anticiper l'esprit civique
est quand même relativement important et
il est clair que si on arrive à bien se
prémunir contre une éventuelle quatrième
vague et bien les conditions économiques
sont bien entendu bienvenus
pour pouvoir redémarrer du bon pied et
retrouvé le niveau de croissance et
d'activité économique on a perdu il y à
18 mois et qui aujourd'hui effectivement
nous préoccupe alors là on parlait des
salariés notamment au contact du public
il ya évidemment le débat sur la
vaccination obligatoire des des
soignants et avant de faire réagir je
voudrais vous faire écouter philippe
martinez secrétaire général de la cgt
qui lui pour le coup c'est s'est
clairement prononcée je ne suis pas
favorable à la vaccination obligatoire
des soignants il vaut mieux convaincre
plutôt que contraindre discuter plutôt
que d'imposer on ne peut pas les montrer
du doigt aujourd'hui après les avoir
applaudi toute l'année dernière et ceci
est valable pour l'ensemble de la
population
c'est vrai que beaucoup d'observateurs
de médecins parlent de faute morale
quand on ne se fait pas vacciner conte
et soignant on a eu des invités de ce
différend syndicalistes de soignants
nous dire nous nous sommes contre à
l'instar d'ailleurs de philippe martinez
quelle est votre position dans votre
syndicat
moi je place jamais les débats sous
l'angle de la moralité
on est dans un pays dans lequel c'est la
loi qui s'applique donc soit la loi et
les bonnes soit la loi elle est pas mal
et on la change donc en l'occurrence si
c'est nécessaire pour des questions
sanitaires j'y reviens de rendre la
vaccination obligatoire et bien rendre
la obligatoire et il faut voir d'où on
vient quand même à ya 18 mois rappelez
vous il n'y avait pas de masque de
disponibles et on nous expliquait que
finalement le masque ça n'était pas
nécessaire
c'était d'ailleurs au passage les
consignes de l' oms c'était très
clairement dit le ministre olivier
verrons nous le disaient les consignes
de l' oms et le masque est réservé aux
soignants
il n'est pas nécessaire d'emporter pour
la population générale et en public
notamment d'extérieur et on voit bien
que les choses changent elles évoluent
moi je ne fais de procès d'intention à
personne
on vit dans des conditions effectivement
précaire au sens où on est confronté à
des situations tout à fait nouvelle moi
je n'aime pas beaucoup si vous voulez
une société dans laquelle on est ambigu
dans laquelle on est floue où on
sollicite chez les gens d'être conforme
à une certaine forme de morale en fait
écouter dans l'organisation syndicale
elle intervient dans la sphère publique
dans l'espace public elle fait référence
à des valeurs nous on en a les valeurs
de l'encadrement la protection des gens
qui s'engagent dans leur carrière dans
leur entreprise
voilà tout ça est une certaine façon
palpable
après la question de savoir si c'est
bien ou si c'est mal mais je pense que
c'est un sujet un peu difficile sur
lequel il est un peu compliquée
d'afficher des certitudes
moi ce que je veux c'est qu'il ya des
consignes qu'elles soient claires et que
surtout on met les moyens en place à
saisir à la disposition de tout le monde
les moyens nécessaires à affronter ses
consignes en fait c'est ça le sujet en
pleine pandémie
la question de la réforme des retraites
revient à un petit peu sur toutes les
lèvres c'est la dernière ligne droite
pour le quinquennal emmanuel macron vous
l'a souhaité non absolument pas non
seulement je la souhaite pas mais je
trouve ce débat un peu inquiétant tout
vous dire
moi je pense que la retraite c'est un
sujet beaucoup trop sérieux beaucoup
trop grave qui concerne tout le monde et
qu'on ne peut pas comme ça le confier à
une petite cellule de communicants qui
prépare telle ou telle campagne
électorale c'est devenu un objet
politique
moi je conteste ça la retraite c'est un
système dans lequel il ya des opérateurs
des opérateurs financiers il ya des gens
qui travaillent dans les conseils et
venir nous dire aujourd'hui la retraite
est en danger catastrophique et c'est
faut absolument faire une réforme
moi je dis que c'est faux parce que eh
bien on a les éléments objectifs qui
nous permettent d'affirmer c'est dans le
d'ailleurs le dernier rapport du conseil
d'orientation des retraites
on a les éléments objectifs qui nous
permettent de dire que les trajectoires
qui permettent d'anticiper les vagues
démographiques sont toujours respectés
malgré la crise est donc absolument pas
d'urgence à démonter il faut affronter
la crise bien la crise elle a impacté
toute l'économie a impacté les comptes
sociaux il n'y a pas de raison tout d'un
coup de prendre pan de panique et de
faire des bêtises sur la retraite c'est
la première chose
et la deuxième chose j'entends dire oui
il faut faire la réforme des retraites
parce qu'après quand on se présente à
une élection qui que ce soit c'est une
image de dire voilà j'ai fait la refais
la réforme j'ai eu du courage
ben écoute et non moi je ne suis pas
d'accord avec ça c'est quoi cette idée
ont fait la réforme n'importe laquelle
pour pouvoir dire j'ai fait une réforme
non c'est pas sérieux une société
effectivement nous en permanence
s'adapter et donc pour cela elle doit se
réformer mais par rapport à des
paramètres qui sont identifiables et on
ne doit pas comme ça cole porter un peu
d des idées catastrophique faire peur
aux gens pour pouvoir faire passer à la
va vite des réformes qui n'ont pas
d'effets positifs moi je veux rappeler
pour finir que le système de retraite
par répartition il se réforment en
permanence depuis 1993 date de la
première réforme vraiment structurantes
pour affronter la vague démographique du
baby-boom devenu le pipi debout mais il
ya eu à peu près six ou sept train de
réformes relativement importante et que
de toute façon les retraites en tendance
quelqu'un qui part en retraite
aujourd'hui il a déjà une retraite d'un
niveau inférieur à celle qu'elle était
il ya 10 ans où il ya 20 ans et donc les
adaptations et les ont été faites il ya
des trajectoires
les trajectoires qui se base sur des
indicateurs économiques sur des
indicateurs démographiques c'est le
premier ordre et il n'y a absolument
aucune urgence exactement la première
phrase du corps il n'y a pas d'urgence à
réformer un système qui est conforme aux
projections que l'on avait avant la
crise merci beaucoup françois om-lille
présidence fcg c'est d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur arte france ce soir
est toujours au chapitre social
principales victimes de la crise
sanitaire les jeunes l'accès à l'emploi
notamment en première ligne un fossé de
plus en plus grands qui s'est creusé
entre les générations malgré des
promesses gouvernementales qui restent
en suspens david khalifa un jeune une
solution slogan phare des manuels mâcon
pour relancer l'accès à l'emploi à des
plus jeunes et en juillet 2020 sur le
papier l'idée est particulièrement
innovante est plutôt intéressante mais
un an plus tard le constat est plutôt
mitigé non pas sur la recherche d'emploi
mais sur l'écart intergénérationnel
provoquée par la crise sanitaire de plus
en plus grands un des coups de la crise
du coc vide s'est fabriqué un gros écart
intergénérationnel en effet il ya un
effet direct qui est que les jeunes ont
du mal à trouver du boulot et un effet
indirect c'est que les politiques
monétaires expansionnistes font monter
les prix des actifs
en conséquence les vieux s'enrichissent
et les jeunes ne peuvent plus acheter de
logements les chiffres parlent d'eux
mêmes en 1995 les moins de 50 ans et les
plus de 60 ans est pratiquement le même
patrimoine
aujourd'hui il ya 60 % d'écart entre les
moins de 50 ans et les plus de 60 ans à
en croire les conclusions du cabinet
épreuve fric mais la crise sanitaire a
mis en avant un autre problème c'est que
les moins de 25 ans se tend de moins en
moins vers l'état pour leurs solutions
financières et préfèrent se tourner vers
leurs familles ce qui engendre
automatiquement des inégalités de plus
en plus flagrante est pourtant emmanuel
macron était plus que jamais déterminé
est passé et ces écarts en prônant
l'égalité des chances pour tous un
investissement de plus de 6 milliards et
demi d'euros pour qu'il n'y ait aucun
jeune sans solution qu'est ce que ça
veut dire qu'on a largement augmenté le
service civique presque doublé qu'on
augmente très fortement aussi les
formations que ce soit des mentions
complémentaire ou les formations dans le
supérieur pour éviter que des jeunes qui
étaient en fin d'études se retrouve sans
employeur sans perspectives
justement en premier cycle universitaire
qu'on fait aussi dans des villes qui
jusqu'àlors n'avaient pas accès à la
formation supérieure ce qui est une une
fonction justement de lutte contre les
inégalités plus de 6 milliards d'euros
investis pour lutter contre la précarité
étudiante
une somme considérable certes mais qui
ne va pas directement dans les poches
les jeunes les différentes solutions
proposées par l'exécutif ne donne pas un
emploi directement aux jeunes mais
encourage la recherche et aiguilles
d'une certaine manière la possibilité de
trouver un travail à la sortie de leurs
études
le problème central c'est l'emploi ce
que veulent les jeunes aujourd'hui
notamment ceux qui font des études
c'est de trouver du boulot or l'état daf
et aucun plan d'embauchés notamment pour
les jeunes
tout ce qu'il a fait ce sont des mesures
d'incitation mais l'incitation ne crée
pas l'emploi l'incitation solution
prônée par le gouvernement donne un
triste bilan
selon un rapport parlementaire sur les
effets de la crise sanitaire sur l'aa
jeunesse les a moins de 30 ans
représentent 35% de la population et
près de 50% des plus pauvres un taux
explicite et un pessimisme dans le plus
en plus pesant pour cette génération
dite sacrifié selon le baromètre annuel
publié par la direction de la recherche
des études de l'évaluation et des
statistiques la semaine dernière le
nombre de personnes affirmant avoir des
difficultés financières est au plus haut
depuis 13 ans en un an le nombre de
jeunes se déclarant pauvres est passé de
20 à 26 % et la crainte de le devenir
prochainement passe de 19 à 21%
les moins de 30 ans forment ainsi la
classe d'âge la plus touchée est la plus
inquiète de tomber dans la pauvreté
un dernier chiffre encore plus explicite
46% les jeunes disent attendre davantage
d'être des pouvoirs publics pour
améliorer leur situation financière
cette année le cri d'alarmé est lancé
reste à savoir s'il sera entendu
alors faut-il un revenu pour ses
étudiants le débat est ouvert pour le
gouvernement regarder ce témoignage de
giuseppe vives étudiant en droit
coordinateur national de l'association
résilience pour lui les
adroit davantage aider les jeunes mais
face à une situation où les étudiants
ont eu des difficultés réelles pour se
nourrir et où les pouvoirs publics ont
très peu réagi en fait pour faire face à
cette situation
dans les faits la vida la douleur place
qui repart à nouveau dans dans les crous
cet amuseur très tardive qui a été
extrêmement limités si on n'habite pas à
côté d'un coup ça on n'a pas l'air par
un euro sur par un euro ils sont
extrêmement extrêmement petit donc on
peut pas vraiment se nourrir
quotidiennement avec cela et et plus
largement les week-ends comment on fait
pendant les vacances scolaires comment
on fait et c'est donc la question se
pose et elle n'a pas été résolu la crise
alimentaire elle va durer et il va
falloir que le gouvernement apporte des
réponses davantage il ya un doute et un
doute évident dans la jeunesse
aujourd'hui on n'a pas une vision sur
sur les années à venir on sait pas
comment ça passe si tu es là quand on
aura fini nos études pour rentrer sur le
marché de l'emploi réellement parce que
là on parle de la ce que je disais sur
les chiffres un jeune sur trois a perdu
son emploi durant la crise sanitaire
en fait on parle d'emploi type pour les
étudiants c'est la restauration c'est
travaille dans un supermarché
si déjà ça c'est pas assurée alors
comment vous voulez qu'une et confiance
pour la suite et par un officier du
droit que je puisse rentrer réellement
dans un cabinet etc
plus tard et faire faire le travail
cette question elle se pose pour tout le
monde et ça c'est dramatique quand on en
est là ce a eu juste des aides
ponctuelles donc on avait 150 euros à
peu près voilà dans ce cas durant la
crise ce qui est ce qu'il ya du tout les
boursiers ont touché un petit peu plus
mais c'est très mal connaître la
situation des étudiants que de limiter
les aides à cela aujourd'hui il faut une
réelle inconnue ce que demandent en tout
cas les organisations étudiantes
demandent la mise en place d' allocation
d'autonomie ou d'un rsa jeunes parce
qu'en fait en dessous de 25 ans quand on
n'a plus de revenus et bien on tombe à
zéro directement il n'y a pas de filet
de sécurité qui existent parce qu'on
peut pas être avoir le rsa
donc c'est une situation absurde qui
doit être corrigé et qui est injuste
parce que quand on est jeune on paie la
tva on travaille
la plupart donc on paye nos impôts il
veut pas pourquoi on n'aurait pas le
droit est ce filet de sécurité
c'est officiel le port du masque ne sera
plus obligatoire en angleterre à partir
du 19 juillet c'est ce qu'a annoncé
boris johnson est une mesure
controversée suite à l'envolée des cas
positifs aux variants delta mais le chef
du gouvernement britannique avait déjà
repoussé la date de la fin des
restrictions du 21 juin au 19 juillet
désormais les britanniques vont devoir
apprendre un livre avec le colis des
annonces faites lors de la conférence de
presse du premier ministre et de son
goût ministre de la santé ont dit nous
allons supprimer toutes les limites
légales sur le nombre de personnes se
réunissant à l'intérieur et à
l'extérieur
nous autorisons la réouverture de tous
les commerces vous avez compris les bois
des deux nuits élèveront la limite sur
les visiteurs nommé dans les maisons de
soins et sur le nombre de personnes
assistant à des concerts des pièces de
théâtre des événements sportifs
enfin à la règle de la distance sociale
de plus d'un mètre et à l'obligation
légale de porter un masque bien que des
conseils suggèreront les endroits où
vous pourriez choisir de le faire tu
particulier lorsque les cas sont en
augmentation
et lorsque vous entrez en contact avec
des personnes que vous ne rencontrez pas
normalement dans des espaces clos tels
que les transports publics
manifestement bondé et pour en parler
nous sommes en direct depuis le au
royaume uni avec bar à tapas en khâgne à
expert en maladies infectieuses à
l'université d'exeter c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir bad bank kenya merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france le port du
masque qui ne sera donc plus obligatoire
dans les lieux publics clos à partir du
19 juillet plus de distanciation sociale
donc le variant delta ne change pas la
donne
thing is it is saisi par cette décision
n'est pas du tout fondées sur la science
nous avons une augmentation des
qualifications et l'ag partie de la
compilation n'a pas encore été vaccinés
il aurait donc été mieux de dire que les
jeux ou jouets a moqué de moi de temps
et lui ressenti n'est il faudrait
continuer à porter le masque alors mal
parti si j'ose dire puisqu'il ya les
demi finales et la finale à wembley
est-ce que clairement ces événements
peuvent t'ils selon vous devenir le
nouveau scandale sanitaire
car tous des gens sur un singe les
plateaux sont susceptibles de contacts
partout où il chante et un parler ou
caen ne respectaient pas les mesures de
sécurité il y aura de la contamination
personnes les plus vulnérables ont déjà
été vaccinées et le vaccin est vite les
femmes grave de la maladie mais avec des
grands rassemblements il y aura plus de
contaminations malheureusement donc on
ne change rien pour boris johnson les
britanniques qui sont appelés d'ailleurs
à vivre avec le virus
c'est un parti pris est-ce que c'est
audible pour un scientifique que vous
êtes
yes we can really c'est le wait because
this is not a vraiment fière qu'on peut
vivre avec le virus ce n'est pas comme
la crise
c'est un virus
dangereuse mais capte l'air grave que
les faits il faut livrer mes vivrait de
façon si sûr et sécurisé le monde il
faut maintenir ses mesures qui empêchent
la contamination pour vous même et pour
les autres qui ne s'alignent pas vivre
avec et en courant le risque de tomber
gravement malade
même si l'on tombe malade est consommé
il peut rester là ce qu'on appelle un
coup vie de long elle ne le savons pas
combien de temps peut durer le
gouvernement donc la première stratégie
est de ne pas être contaminé ne pas
contaminer autrui d'être très prudent et
de maintenir les sécurité est clairement
un aveu d'échec la part du premier
ministre britannique et est d'une
certaine manière un aveu d'échec des
politiques de santé des gouvernements
est ce que on arrive réellement
aujourd'hui à lutter contre ce virus
il devient de plus en plus difficile
aura émis elle est en bonne posture car
nous avons largement vacciner non
abandonner les mesures de sécurité les
mesures de contrôle de la contamination
il lancé du court termisme du mic pour
feelgood premier ministre boris johnson
elle rendre les gens heureux la faire
plaisir mais parfois les personnalités
politiques doivent prendre les décisions
difficiles
un peu couvert par exemple il faudrait
décider que partout où on se trouve dans
des moments lieu on ya beaucoup de gens
dans un supermarché dans le bus dans la
foule il faudrait porter le masque afin
de se protéger soi même et les autres
bancaires vous avez toujours dit que les
vaccins et efficace contre
les variants du covin notamment le delta
mais on voit en ce moment qu'on y
seraient inquiets quand même aussi l'un
des pays les plus avancés concernant la
vaccination est bien on assiste
justement un rebond de ces
contaminations est ce que ça remet en
cause l'efficacité de ce vaccin
le dews
je suis effectivement un courant de
cette l'efficacité il légèrement réduite
contre le variant delta existant en
israël mais le vaccin protège toujours
et le vaccin est vite l'hospitalisation
et les formes graves de la maladie
effectivement une légère réduction de
l'is nature qu'à citer car le virus est
bien plus prestigieux et c'est
d'ailleurs pour toi je pense qu'il est
allé bien d'être vaccinés il compte
également 1 a bien diminué malgré tout à
porter le masque et s'assurer une bonne
ventilation pour éviter la contamination
merci baraquements kenya expert en
maladies infectieuses d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons du système kovacs le
président vénézuélien nicolás maduro a
lancé un ultimatum ils auraient payé
près de 120 millions d'euros sont
recevoir la moindre dose
et puis nous écopons l'afghanistan où
les insurgés viennent de prendre le
contrôle d'une zone clé proche de
kandahar et possède désormais plus d'une
centaine de district
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk nous sommes au
bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe
nous sommes à chez vox harry
allons faire connaissance
vous avez choisi le jour à bagdad alors
je suis arrivé en 2005 pour étudier
dernière fois celle en profiter en 2011
elle ne demande pas un petit peu non ah
oui et c'est tous les fromages tous les
soucis sont toutes les décroissants la
pâtisserie traits de caractère des
russes qui te plaît l'amitié les gens
les gens très stylée les français ne
savent pas je ne pensais jamais de ma
vie faire la courge autonomie vous
pouvez me souhaiter bon courage
[Musique]
à très bientôt sur arte france
l'idée c'est que lorsque les cellules de
la rétine ne sont plus capables de
répondre à la lumière puisqu'elles ont
dégénéré de rendre ces cellules
sensibles à la lumière nous sommes
inspirés une découverte qui avaient été
faites par des gens qui travaillaient
sur les alpes kb identifié chez les
algues des protéines qui répondent à la
lumière et entraîne la formation d'un
courant électrique comme le font les
neurones et comme le font normalement
les cellules sensibles à la lumière dans
la rétine pas ce qu'il va dire qu'il
voit un peu c'est il distingue la
lumière il distingue quoi exactement par
le bastien est capable par exemple de
reconnaître les passages protégés dans
la rue de détecter des objets différents
objets de petite taille de grande taille
plusieurs niveaux de pompage de les
compter de les attraper
mais comme c'est un patient qui ne
voyait plus rien depuis une quinzaine
d'années c'est déjà une source d'espoir
c'est évidemment pas un point définitif
du parcours c'est un une étape franchie
[Musique]
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france si vous nous rejoignez le
vaccin comme seul moyen de prévenir une
nouvelle vague épidémique dans le monde
alors que le variant d'elle pas fait
craindre le pire problème les deux stars
arrivées dans les pays les plus pauvres
la faute à une distribution inéquitable
le programme kovacs censé aider les plus
défavorisés coince les précisions de
maxime abers depuis sa mise en place en
2020 sous l'égide de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé le programme kovacs
peine à tenir ses promesses
le dernier à s'en prendre aux programmes
de solidarité censé redistribuer des
doses des pays riches vers les pays sous
développés n'est d'autre que nicholas
maduro le système kovacs doit arrêter de
se moquer du peuple vénézuélien
soit ils nous envoient les vaccins
soient ils rendent notre argent point
final
et si nous rende notre argent nous
serons allés pour les acheter le
président vénézuélien est catégorique
pour les 120 millions de dollars que son
pays a mis au pot commun aucune dose n'a
été fourni sans attendre le pays s'est
donc tourné vers des accords binationaux
et vaccine majoritairement à coups de
doses russe et chinoise face à cette
pénurie
le venezuela utilise aussi le vaccin
cubain alors qu'il n'a reçu ni le feu
vert des autorités cubaines ni celui de
l' oms coupable désigné pour maduro les
états unis depuis 2019
washington refuse de le reconnaître
comme président légitime et aurait
bloqué les financements à destination de
caracas préférence nationale dont tardif
et donc peut-être choix politiques
pourtant en marge du sommet du g7 joe
biden s'était engagé à verser 500
millions de doses sans condition à une
centaine de pays
paradoxalement toujours via kovacs le
salvador a récemment accueilli 2
millions de doses en provenance du
voisin américain
sur le continent africain c'est l'union
européenne qui en prend pour son grade
notre scène grunge pas une seule dose
pas une seule folle n'a quitté une usine
européenne pour l'afrique
quand nous sommes allés parler à leurs
fabricants ils nous ont dit qu'ils
étaient au maximum de leurs capacités
qu'il répondait aux besoins de l'europe
on nous renvoie vers l'inde va qu'ils
ont vacciné un si grand nombre de leurs
concitoyens qu'ils peuvent désormais
aller voir un match de football sans
masquer notre peuple n'a pas été
vaccinées moins de 1 % de notre
population a été vaccinée dès mars
l'inde principal pourvoyeur de ce
programme mondial a suspendu ses
livraisons face à l'explosion des cas
sur son sol alors certains pays
africains où dû faire cavalier seul
le nigeria a décidé de se doter de son
propre vaccin
le maroc a lui profité de ses liens avec
pékin pour recevoir des injections de
sinopharm et sinovac
mais les laboratoires chinois accusent
eux aussi des retards des mécanismes
régionaux cette fois ont donc pris le
relais
c'est le cas de la vàd en afrique
financé lui aussi par la banque mondiale
et qui devrait bénéficier à 60% de la
population du continent
fin février le patron de l'om est accusé
certains pays riches de saper kovacs en
continuant d'approcher les fabricants
pour s'assurer l'accès à des doses de
vaccins supplémentaires au 30 juin
le programme a expédié plus de 89
millions de vaccins à 133 pays et
territoires participants selon les
nations unies
loin très loin de l'objectif des 1,8
milliard de doses distribuées avant la
fin de l'année
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
romain miguet journaliste spécialiste de
l'amérique latine fondateur également du
site francophone d'actualité et
d'amérique latine les deux rives point
info bonsoir en main les bus merci
d'être avec nous on va essayer de
comprendre ce qui se passe au venezuela
pourquoi le système kovacs n'a pas livré
les doses achetées
alors c'est une histoire qui traîne
c'est le lait l'interview là que vous
venez de passer de nicolás maduro
en fait c'est une histoire un peu plus
longues n'ont depuis le mois d'avril le
venezuela dont qui je le répète sous
blocus financier des états unis a eu
toutes les peines du monde mais a
réalisé plus de 12 transactions pour un
montant de 110 millions de dollars des
u11 d'ailleurs à communiquer de kovacs
le 13 avril 2021 qui soulignait que
l'alliance mondiale pour les vaccins et
l'immunisation avait bien reçu la
totalité 109,9 millions de dollars et
qu'il manquait encore 15 millions de
dollars qui avaient été bloqués par la
banque suisse ubs donc en raison des
sanctions imposées par les états unis
alors visiblement ces fonds auraient été
débloquées toujours est il que le
venezuela n'a pas reçu de vaccin
malgré le fait qu'ils ont débloqué
qu'ils ont payé 120 millions de dollars
donc d'où l'interrogation de nicolás
maduro si vous n'êtes pas en mesure de
nous les livre et rendez-nous l'argent
et alors est ce que l'argent va être
rendue après oui c'est il ya tout à fait
évidemment il ya un problème aussi
juridique puisque comme gelée soulignait
tout à l'heure le venezuela est sous
blocus financière depuis ce criminel
imposé par les états unis et leurs
alliés
il semblerait tout de même que
le lot est mais ce devrait être en
capacité de réaliser des transactions
financières avec le venezuela puisque il
y a eu lie a par le passé
en tout cas les deux dernières années il
ya eu des accords entre l'organisation
panaméricaine de la santé donc la
branche de l'om est pour l'amérique
latine et le venezuela pour réaliser
différents types de transactions
notamment poro pour l'achat de vaccins
alors pas forcément le coc vide mais
pour l'achat de vaccins courant pour
pouvoir vacciner les enfants notamment
au venezuela donc on espère un ne pas
forcément pour le venezuela juste pour
le droit international
on espère que cet argent sera rendu et
on espère surtout que les vaccins
pourront arriver au venezuela et que le
venezuela pourra compter sur les 5
millions de vaccins qu'ils ont commandés
à kovacs et qui viendront en
complémentarité des vaccins russes
chinois et cubains qui sont utilisés
aujourd'hui pour vacciner les manèges le
lien alors selon les déclarations de
nicholas maduro ans les états unis
auraient bloqué un paiement de 10
millions de dollars au système commerce
pour quelles raisons alors c'est on va
dire c'est une une conséquence du blocus
financier c'est-à-dire que les
transactions financières avec l'état
vénézuélien sont interdites de manière
unilatérale par le gouvernement des
états unis et les entreprises
financières ou commerciales qui
réalisent des transactions avec le
gouvernement vénézuélien passe
immédiatement dans la liste du
département du trésor des états unis
donc son elle-même placée sous sanction
et je pense que c'est pour cela que la
banque suisse ubs a congelé en tout cas
pendant un temps un peu plus de 10
millions de dollars qui était destiné à
aller sur le compte de
de l'om est-ce pour l'achat des vaccins
alors c'est très bien d'ailleurs que
cette histoire explose sur fond de
vaccination qu'ovide parce que c'est ce
blocus financier
et bien c'est une des principales causes
de la crise économique qui s'abat sur le
peuple vénézuélien depuis maintenant six
ans alors malgré toutes les promesses un
des pays occidentaux pour le moment on
peut clairement dire que ce système est
un échec d'autres pays n'ont pas reçu
ses livraisons prévues alors à ma
connaissance et en dehors de l'afrique
que je ne connais moi j'ai écouté le
l'interview que vous venez de passer en
amérique latine même si c'est au
compte-gouttes le venezuela reste le
seul pays hors ue cuba évidemment mais
cuba cuba développe son propre vaccin
le venezuela reste le seul pays où les
vaccins ont été niés par par kovacs donc
nous verrons dans les prochaines dans
les prochains jours le dénouement de
cette affaire ainsi le venezuela peut
récupérer soit sans argent ou soit
récupéré les vaccins qui l'a tout de
même payés le venezuela vous l'avez dit
harvey milk gus à ceux fournis et on l'a
entendue dans le sujet a également avec
le vexin russe pour nick v le chinois
sinopharm à et le cubain abdallah est ce
qu'il a réellement besoin de ce
dispositif
kovacs pour vacciner sa population
écoutez il se trouve que c'est on parle
là de 5 millions de doses donc ce n'est
pas rien non plus 1 2 qui viennent
s'ajouter donc aux 12 millions de doses
du vaccin abdallah mais le mc saïda a
besoin de trois injections donc les 12
millions de doses concernerait 4 million
de personnes plus les vaccins scouts
nick 5 comme vous venez de le mentionner
et les vaccins chinois
je pense que dans la lutte contre le
le kobe 19 le gouvernement vénézuélien
et c'est d'être le plus large possible
pour arriver à ces objectifs qui est de
vacciner 70 % de sa population à la fin
de l'année et donc on leur souhaite bien
évidemment de rentrer dans cet objectif
avec toutes les aides possibles et
inimaginables à un niveau multilatéral
merci beaucoup romain miguet d'avoir été
avec moi en direct sur rt france
merci à vous il ya 59 ans jour pour jour
les algériens accéder à l'indépendance
après 132 ans de colonisation française
depuis ils n'ont connu qu'une formation
politique au pouvoir le fln front de
libération nationale un parti rejetée
par le mouvement du irak déclenchée en
février 2019 menant au départ de blaise
bouteflika les explications en images
c'était le 1er juillet 1962 les
algériens se rendaient en masse pour
voter au référendum leur donnant accès à
l'indépendance le oui l'emportent à
99,72 % le 3 juillet 1962 le général de
gaulle signe la déclaration
d'indépendance le 5 juillet finalement
retenu pour célébrer la libération dans
le but d'effacer la date de la chute
d'alger en 1830
malgré un sentiment de libération et les
cris de joie des algériens les années
qui suivent sont marquées par une
succession de crises politiques dès
l'indépendance c'est le front de
libération nationale qui arrivent au
pouvoir refusant toute opposition en
1980 de nombreux algériens demandent un
gouvernement plus démocratique
chadli bendjedid est au pouvoir et doit
faire face à leur colère
d'importants mouvements de protestation
se succèdent jusqu'à la guerre civile
en 1991 dans les années 1990 l'algérie
traverse une décennie noire marquée par
l'affrontement entre militaires et
divers groupes islamistes armés
islamique du salut ou encore groupe
islamique armé en 1999 une nouvelle tête
arrive au pouvoir
mais le parti reste le même abdelaziz
bouteflika devient président il restera
vingt ans au pouvoir avant que l'irak ne
vienne mettre un terme à son mandat
ce mouvement de protestation d'attentes
de février 2019 réclame le démantèlement
du système de gouvernance une
souveraineté nationale et populaire ou
encore l'égalité hommes femmes
c'est dans la foulée qu est élu à la
présidence algérienne abdelmadjid
tebboune appartenant lui aussi au fln
en juin 2021 les partisans du irak
rejette des élections législatives et
appellent au boycott du scrutin
un appel qui ne porte pas ses fruits car
le fln sort de nouveau vainqueur du vote
malgré un taux d'abstention historique
atteignant 70 7%
le nouvel échiquier politique algérien
fait tout de même perdre 50 sièges au
fln lui laissant 105 strapontin sur les
407 que le parti doit partager avec son
allié le rassemblement national
démocratique et les partis d'opposition
malgré cela mercredi 30 juin 2021 le
président nomme un nouveau chef du
gouvernement
le technocrate aymen ben abderrahmane ex
ministre des finances
[Musique]
en afghanistan les talibans intensifient
leur offensive contre les forces
afghanes pour prendre le contrôle de
zones rurales à travers le pays
il possède désormais une centaine de
district une progression et des attaques
alors que le retrait total des troupes
américaines doit s'achever d'ici la fin
août françois this kevin ch
les combats font rage près de fès abad
capitale de la province du badakshan les
forces de sécurité afghanes tentent de
reprendre le contrôle de district perdu
après une offensive des talibans dans
les dernières heures des forces
spéciales et des commandos sont arrivés
au bataclan
nous allons bientôt commencer nos
opérations de nettoyage pour reprendre
les zones qui ont été perdus des
défaites la plupart du temps sans combat
en infériorité numérique et sans
ravitaillement de nombreux soldats de
l'armée afghane ont fui leur avant-poste
militaire laissant la voie libre aux
talibans offensive talibane au nord mais
aussi au sud dans la province de
kandahar berceau du mouvement
les talibans se sont emparés d'un
district clé située à une quinzaine de
kilomètres de la capitale provinciale
au même moment ce dimanche le secrétaire
du gouverneur de kandahar est tué par
l'explosion de sa voiture et dans les
villages des familles prennent la fuite
nous devrions nous aller nos enfances
dans la voiture sous cette chaleur
les soldats nous ont dit de ne pas
passer par ce côté de la ville mais nous
ne les avons pas écouté puis les
talibans nous ont tiré dessus depuis les
montagnes nos forces de sécurité sont
assises à côté de la route
mais il tire depuis les montagnes les
talibans affirment contrôler une
centaine de district sur les près de 400
que compte le pays
un chiffre contesté par les autorités
afghanes qui admettent pourtant que les
forces gouvernementales se sont retirées
de certains districts
la seule chose qui me perçois draps de
poser mon arme et qu'il y est ici une
loi islamique
entièrement basé sur l'islam et que le
gouvernement soit dirigé selon les
règles islamiques des événements qui
interviennent quelques jours après le
départ des troupes américaines et de
l'otan de bagram leur base la plus
importante en afghanistan et centre
névralgique des opérations de la
coalition contre les insurgés islamistes
ces vingt dernières années washington a
d'ailleurs annoncé ce vendredi que le
retrait total des troupes américaines
serait achevé d'ici fin août un retrait
responsable selon certains observateurs
des récentes conquêtes talibane les
forces de sécurité afghanes ne
bénéficiant plus du soutien aérien
jusqu'ici fournis par l'armée américaine
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
pierre conesa ancien haut fonctionnaire
spécialiste des questions stratégiques
internationales bonsoir pierre connaît
sa merci d'être avec nous
direct sur rt france quand on voit ce
sujet on se demande jusqu'où la
progression des taliban peut-elle aller
ils ont déjà grignoté beaucoup de
terrain alors que les américains n'ont
même pas encore complètement quitté le
pays
oui effectivement on va voir le scénario
qui est le retour des talibans au
pouvoir
le il est évident que si vous voulez
l'intrusion d'une tierce partie dans la
situation de l'afghanistan est
évidemment un phénomène perturbateurs
qui conduit pratiquement à l'union
désherbant contre l'étranger
c'est assez paradoxal mais c'est comme
ça et deuxième chose l'état normal de
l'afghanistan c'est la crise c'est pas
la stabilité donc beaucoup de comment
dire d'étrangers que ce soit qu'ils
soient russes en 79 qu'ils soient
américains en 2002 ont toujours pensé
que leur simple arrivée la promesse du
régime qu'ils allaient installer
suffiraient à calmer ce qui est un état
de guerre civile latente afghanistan en
afghanistan est une conglomérat de chef
de guerre ces chefs de guerre dont comme
vocation que de défendre leur ethnie et
donc comme disait l'un d'entre eux
d'ailleurs aidé m on peut pas acheter un
chef de guerre afghan mais on peut le
louer
bon c'est beau ça vous donne l'avantagé
si vous voulez du rapport à la violence
dans cette danse pays qui incapables de
rétablir la situation
l'autre aspect qui est extrêmement
important c'est la lassitude de
l'opinion publique américaine
c'est évidemment ma question suivante
c'est un échec patent de don de cette
stratégie américaine tout ça pour ça
aussi bien voilà des vies perdues de
l'argent du temps pour arriver justement
a quasiment le point zéro
oui même si vous laissez le n'est pas le
seul exemple de résultats
catastrophiques de l'espèce du bri
guerrière qui s'est emparée des pays
occidentaux qui se sont créés en charge
de faire une espèce de police
internationale bon et donc l'essentiel
des interventions qui se sont d'ailleurs
concentrées conseil très concentré
pardon sur le moyen orient ont toutes
tourné à l'échec que ce soit en irak
que ce soit en afghanistan encore une
fois parce que la légitimité de
l'intervention occidentale elle peut
être motivée par de très bons moyens qui
nous paraissent loup significative mais
qui sombre et comme une invasion armée
par les habitants donc il faut cesser de
penser qu'on peut résoudre des crises
politique par des moyens militaires
c'est par un conseil que je donne aux
dirigeants occidentaux
donc le bilan de 10 ans 15 ans six
volets d'intervention militaire est
totalement négative
excepté la bosnie il ya eu aucun
résultat positif aujourd'hui clairement
que va devenir ce pays on imagine que
les talibans vont peut-être aller
jusqu'à la chute du gouvernement
d'ashraf ghani oui oui on peut tout à
fait le penser cela dit est ce que le
retour des talibans au pouvoir en
afghanistan suffira à stabiliser si vous
voulez encore une fois cet équilibre
instable qui est la situation de
l'afghanistan dont les talibans sont en
majorité des pachtouns c'est-à-dire de
l'ethnie dominante mais ils ne sont pas
seuls en mesure de contrôler la totalité
du territoire donc on sera dans une
espèce d'état de paix armée simplement
tout ce qu'on peut espérer c'est qu'on
canalise sauver cette violence pour
empêcher qu'elle ne diffuse sur la
périphérie
il ya eu pourtant des négociations entre
américains et talibans est ce que
c'était ce qu'il fallait faire c'était
la bonne stratégie
ça a été fait comme une espèce de
préparation au départ c'est à dire pour
montrer que washington était prêt à
s'asseoir à une table de négociation
avec ses pires ennemis et puis
effectivement l'intention n'était pas la
même des deux côtés c'est à dire quoi
chine donne n'étaient pas décidés à
rester jusqu'à l'issue des négociations
puisque finalement le retrait a été
annoncée déjà en partie un parent trap
est définitivement par eden donc on est
effectivement la situation que c'était
une pseudo négociations qui devaient
permettre de partir disons un peu
dignement pour les troupes américaines
mais c'est une véritable catastrophe un
c'est une évidence
l'armée afghane a pourtant été formés
pendant donc c
et l'ont emmenée par l'armée américaine
ça veut dire qu'il ne reste rien
pourquoi elles sont si compliqués c'est
compliqué parce qu'encore une fois si
vous voulez un afghan à deux appartenant
si peu d'afghans et en même temps il va
être pachtoune il va être taji qui va
être ce que vous voulez si vous voulez
rien c'est une mosaïque d'ethnies
l'afghanistan et n'oublie pas que c'est
une zone de confort entre les empires
c'est à dire d'avant voit dans ce
qu'elles se sont réfugiés dans le dans
toute la chaîne de l'hindu kuch tout des
populations qui étaient persécutés à
droite et à gauche donc ce n'est pas un
pays ce n'est pas une nation
l'afghanistan c'est un espèce d'état
tampon qui s'était constitué entre l'
empire angle l empire russe etc et donc
toutes ces populations ont appris à se
défendre elle même et se défendre elle
même ça veut dire se défendent
éventuellement contre d'autres c'est dit
donc il faut pas qu'on arrive nous en
disant nous avons la solution rappelez
vous la solution bhl qui ce président
commandant massoud comme la solution
c'était une espèce d'escroquerie
intellectuelle
personne ne peut penser que a fortiori
un tadjik minorité minorité en
afghanistan allait assurer le pouvoir
sans prendre en afghanistan dont on est
encore une fois sur cette logique on
croit que nous occidentaux on va imposer
un modèle d'état et rappelez-vous cette
extraordinaire annonce si vous voulez
qu'on allait faire là bas ce que les
américains avaient trouvé c'est à dire
d'annoncer justifier la guerre en
afghanistan pour libérer la femme
afghane
bon pour ceux qui ont bien peu les
viandes aplatissant ils savent très bien
que si vous explique un afghan vous avez
libérer sa femme et sa fille vous êtes
sûr de vous en faire un ennemi d'envoyer
ce décalage psychologie politique
sociale etc conduisait à l'échec et
c'est de fait ce qui s'est passé que les
russes c'est ce qui se passe rien passé
et tous les américains ce qui s'était
d'ailleurs pas c'est que les anglais au
dix neuvième siècle
merci beaucoup en tout cas pierre conesa
nos avoirs à apporter vos lumière sur
cette situation en afghanistan où les
taliban je le disais donc ne cesse de
gagner
du terrain merci à vous et dans le reste
de l'actualité au chili la toute
nouvelle assemblée constituante a élu sa
présidente une femme indigène originaire
de la tribu mapuches
mais cette nouvelle ère démarre sous
tension hier la session inaugurale a été
suspendu en raison d'affrontements avec
la police devant l'ancien parlement
walid bennani et luis salom comme
noventa essai elle est celle qui
représente désormais l'espoir au chili
et ben issa london universitaire mapuche
et militante des droits indigènes
désignée nouvelle présidente de la
convention constitutionnelle
[Applaudissements]
mais dans cette convention que je doit
présider aujourd'hui transformera le
chili en un chili plurinational et
interculturel l ont-ils en au chili
qu'il ne viole pas les droits des femmes
et des soignants et non à peine des
progrès sur de l'amour et des han au
chili qui prend soin de la terre mais
elissalde kohn qui occupe l'un des 17
sièges réservés aux groupes indigènes a
été élu au deuxième tour
96 personnes ont voté pour sa nomination
sur les 155 membres de l'assemblée
la rédaction de cette nouvelle
constitution bel et bien actée par un
référendum au mois de mai dernier
serein si le travail d'une assemblée
respectons la parité soit 118 hommes et
77 femmes objectif rompre définitivement
avec les inégalités sociales et les
fantômes du passé ceux d'une précédente
constitution écrite sous la dictature
d'augusto pinochet qui a duré de 1973 à
1990 un nouveau chili pluriel
multilingue et fondé avec toutes les
cultures et les peuples avec les femmes
avec les territoires
c'est notre rêve d'écrire une nouvelle
constitution
et une population chilienne sous tension
à l'image de manifestations ayant marqué
la journée de dimanche
[Applaudissements]
plusieurs affrontements ont eu lieu avec
des forces anti émeutes devant l'ancien
parlement entraînant une suspension de
près de trois heures de la première
session de l'assemblée constituante
[Musique]
des images rappelant les grands
rassemblements d'octobre 2010 9 et la
fronde sociale liés notamment à une
hausse du prix du ticket de métro à
santiago
parce qu'il n'est pas convenable que
nous commencions un processus
démocratique de cette ampleur avec des
pressions politiques au chili alors la
première chose est de libérer les
prisonniers de la révolte
ensuite ce qui est important dans ce
processus c'est que les citoyens et le
peuple puisse participer et participer
au processus
un processus et des travaux qui
devraient durer neuf mois minimum un an
maximum
la nouvelle constitution sera dans la
foulée soumise à référendum en 2022 et
en cas de désaveu
la constitution actuelle restera en
vigueur et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci d'avoir suivi on se
retrouve dans quelques minutes pour 1
point complet sur l'actualité
[Musique]
au carrefour d'une pollution
un supporter est d'une nécessité
technologique absolue les terres rares
sont au coeur des défis du 21e siècle
c'est un enjeu stratégique pour tous les
prix puisque leur accès est aujourd'hui
principalement chinois en l'état actuel
des capacités minières connu la part
chinoise et réserve mondiale est de
l'ordre de 37 % dans la cadre de la
guerre commerciale avec les états unis
la chine utilise sa position comme
levier de négociations mais il est clair
qu'avec les pénuries et les tensions que
nous allons connaître sur certaines
terres rares il faut envisager d'autres
solutions
[Musique]
que se passe-t-il concrètement pour vous
depuis que le graet ci est officiel les
systèmes douaniers étaient compliquées
par la mise en oeuvre du rexy le vrai
sujet c'est celui de faire dialoguer les
douaniers français les poignées
britannique est ce qui m'inquiète dans
le bric side c'est pas le président
c'est la bureaucratie du bixi comment ça
va se passer par exemple pour l'été qui
arrive la côte d'azur verra peu ou pas
d'anglais
je suspecte effectivement le
gouvernement britannique d'essayer de
convaincre les britanniques de rester en
grande bretagne pour faciliter la
relance de l'économie britannique